my thing was I wanted to learn the
difference between fear and intuition
right yeah
right God damn it it's such a hard one
it's such a fine line I have read
everything and watched every YouTube
video Guru purse that talks about it you
know
um if it's fear you don't want to do it
and I'm like I don't think that's right
you know I think you for me I think when
we get stuck on the fear and intuition
we we fear making a bad decision right I
don't want to make a bad decision I want
more in fear we fear making a bad
decision right right okay so I I said
you know what instead of putting so much
pressure on myself to know that this is
intuition that I'm making because
intuition is the right decision right so
instead of putting so much pressure on
myself to like is this intuition I just
said I'm gonna go with energy feels good
right and if something scares me but I
know I should do it I'm going to do it
and I'm going to parent myself through
it right to help myself and letting go
of the need to have all all the
decisions be right and correct in my
life so can I make a bad decision pick
the wrong person and be okay with that
it just takes this pressure off of
yourself and if you can listen to
yourself if you have that conversation
with that part of yourself that inner
child and really wholeheartedly sit with
her she's in the chair and you're the
therapist I always tell people if you
want to do this exercise you have to
learn how to detach from that voice from
that you know little voice within that
inner child so imagine you sitting here
and being the child worry fear stress
anxiety insecurity everything that comes
up right and then you turning around and
you're the parent or the therapist and
help her through what she's feeling
because sometimes she doesn't even know
what she's feeling she's just feeling
something yeah she's just worried and
helping her break down what's really the
problem here what are you really nervous
about
then you start to kind of like break
fears down and then they don't have as
much energetic pull over you to kind of
like mess with your life
so fear is making a fear is the fear of
making a bad decision yeah fear is more
paralyzing yes yes 100 and intuition is
more action
it is more action but you know with
intuition
when she's talking do you listen and
what is she saying like I always try to
like have like a really good
conversation with her to understand like
do you really want to do this like what
are you really scared of you know and a
lot of it is pain I'm just scared of
pain
okay well what pain
and then don't get me wrong there are
times where I'm like do you want to do
this and if you listen to her if it's
intuition she'll go no that's a hard no
I don't want to do this I don't feel
like this person's right okay so what's
really going on well I don't want to be
alone I'm bored
I'm lonely I'm feeling insecure whatever
I haven't had sex in a while whatever
whatever it is right so it's you really
just have to like listen to her and have
conversations with her and she'll guide
you I'm glad you said the word sex
because I wanted to ask you about that
man it always seems like the most
prevalent indicator it's not the most
important thing you can work on that
right right but yet it really becomes
this barometer of connection
is that what you found in coaching is
that what you found in in experiencing
couples and how do you create a healthy
sex life is it an actual like thing that
you talk about agree to or is it more
symptomatic
well I mean I think different phases of
different relationships you know what I
mean like obviously in the beginning you
should be having amazing sex all the
time no fighting it's it's great and you
know as the relationship what's all
what's the how long is that supposed to
last some people are like yeah I want to
live in the honeymoon phase forever and
you should and well yeah everybody does
but realistically like how long should
you be in the honeymoon phase versus you
know versus not because it can be an
indicator of issues I still feel like
I'm in a honeymoon phase just now
there's other real life that also is
here with us do you know what I mean so
like in the beginning when I was when we
were dating we weren't taught we weren't
dealing with each other's families or
your mom needs to go to the doctor or
this needs to have there wasn't life
really happening yeah kids like all
right will you go pick him up at soccer
and then this has to happen like none of
that was happening there was no stress
it was just fun times because now
there's still fun times there is not as
many because now we have life and
responsibilities but there's still
playfulness there's still great sex
there's not as much great sex as there
was in the beginning because there's
responsibilities so if you're
communicating and like Hey we're having
a date night in a while and like hey we
need to focus on ourselves I mean we're
lucky because we're both divorced and so
we kind of have built-in babysitters but
from the people that don't and they have
to like really make it a point to spend
that time with each other if there are
families and children involved it is
harder you know you have to really plan
how to you know keep that spark alive
but you know think about like during
covid when we were like all in
quarantine and like you were trapped in
the house with your husband or your
girlfriend or kids or whatever you can
still be I think playfulness is like
that was something that I said early on
when I was dating I'm like I want
playfulness I want to be 80 years old
and you still walk by me in the kitchen
and smack my ass like 100 like beef I
want to be fun you know because life's
so stressful and there's so much going
on all the time that if you can't like
just be on the couch and just play and
be silly play is something that people
get into when they're in the mental
emotional state of wanting to be playful
like wanting to have fun wanting to let
go of the stress of life so when I get
into a playful state with their person
with their person yeah so like when I
get into a playful State I make it a
point because I want to laugh right like
I want to take away I think people take
life just too seriously and I sometimes
say this more with women than men where
they're like don't Smack My Ass or
they're just like Moody and they're
defensive because they're stressed
they're tired I get it I'm a woman I
have children I have a business I
totally understand what that means but
you have to be able to own your own
happiness so regardless of my life and
kids and responsibility and stress and
whatever I want to have a good day today
do you know what I mean like that's you
know it's a more Sovereign experience in
your day so whatever the other person
isn't so what if the other person isn't
into it
um so then you're not swimming in the
same pool
so then what do you do when I started
coaching there was a woman that I
remember having a conversation with and
she said um I have a coach friend and
she works with couples and all she does
is she re readjusts their uh
relationship agreement and I was like oh
that's interesting so she said they come
to me before they get married they draft
their group what is their marriage going
to look like who's going to work who's
going to manage the kids who's going to
do this before they have kids maybe they
come back and they redo the agreement
okay now we're having kids so sex gonna
sex is going to go away for a little bit
this is so they're always talking about
what kind of relationship do you
actually want and I think that's
important to kind of sit with your
partner and say hey we've been together
for a year like what do you want more of
what do I want more of and just
negotiate your contract with each other
what can you compromise with what can't
you what are you putting on your partner
to be responsible for in terms of your
own happiness versus the things that
like I said the playfulness I don't do
it for him I don't do it to be cute for
him you know what I mean I do it for me
me because it feels good because it
feels good yeah and I I also want our
kids to see a healthy relationship a
happy relationship I never saw my
parents kissing and hugging and being
playful and silly you know even though
they're you know nine and eleven and
eight they get grossed out but that's
okay you know we're not doing anything
appropriate inappropriate and they
should see happy parents that are in
love that are you know holding each
other that are being playful what do you
say to couples that are staying married
for the kids I mean I've had friends
growing up where their parents did that
and the problem
because I think in their mind they think
they're doing you know such a service to
the kids and they're just so not well
because they're showing them you're not
you're not kissing you're not slapping
asses you're not laughing if you're not
in a relationship you want to be if
you're in a relationship you don't want
to be in so you're demonstrating
um a lifestyle a relationship to the
children that is not a good one and I
think you know we have this like I don't
know if it started in the 80s probably
because that's really when divorce just
kind of took off but we have this thing
that like if we're separating you get
divorced the kids are gonna be all
screwed up and it's like you couldn't be
further from the truth kids yeah kids
always want their parents to be together
of course but they just want their
parents happy like I didn't give I
didn't care at all that my parents were
divorced I care that they hated each
other
um
so if parents are happy and they can be
separate you know yes it'll still be
difficult for everyone because their
shared time and I I miss Mom and I want
to go whatever but you can manage that
way easier than to people that hate each
other or two people that are together
that don't like each other you would
advise to move on fix your own self not
your not your partner you know don't
worry about your partner and what
they're doing and picking at them work
on you so when I coach couples I don't
coach them together I coach them
individually because if I coach them
together it constantly is a what am I
not getting in this relationship what is
this person doing wrong rather than
saying what are you doing that's causing
the things in the relationship that you
don't like
because if you can own your stop and
vacant on theirs you'll have a great
relationship what are the what's some of
the best things to ask yourself say if
conflict comes up like what are a couple
things that you can do to take like the
First Steps the best steps towards
resolution
why do I feel this way
and really understanding what that means
not why do I feel this way because they
did this
go deeper than that
you can go deeper then yeah you'll get
to like the root of what's bothering you
versus what you think is bothering you
is what they're doing yeah so it's not
that they left the socks on the floor
it's not that they never pick the
restaurant if you like this clip and you
want to hear the whole episode click at
the bottom of your screen
[Music]